TODD WOMACK: Come on!
Yes!
Come on!
Look at that.
PAUL SCHEER: Thank you.
All right.
This is exciting.
TODD WOMACK: An afternoon
with Paul Scheer.
Look at-- this is--
PAUL SCHEER: Look, I would love
to spend an afternoon with each
of you right here.
We're going to hang out.
We're going to really
get down to it.
TODD WOMACK: That's the plan.
We're scheduled to go till--
PAUL SCHEER: We are
real real today.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah, we have
the room until 11:00 PM.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, great.
Big epic thing.
Who was here before me?
TODD WOMACK: Everyone
was here before you.
PAUL SCHEER: Ah, damn it.
Always happens.
But this is a week full
of interesting people.
So I feel like I
have to top that.
I have to kind of
admit something.
In the course of
this interview, I'm
going to have to admit
something terrible.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
That sounds great.
PAUL SCHEER: Maybe I'll
say I killed somebody
and we'll get a lot of hits.
But I'll do it right
at the very end,
so people have to watch the
whole video the whole way
through.
TODD WOMACK: Watch all the ads.
PAUL SCHEER: You've
got to get those ads.
Bank of America, got it, I'm in.
Pantene Pro V. Yeah, I saw it.
TODD WOMACK: I don't
think they're going
to be running Pantene Pro V.
PAUL SCHEER: No,
they love Pantene.
Look, there's hair other places.
TODD WOMACK: There is.
Cool man.
PAUL SCHEER: Why do I have
to treat that with this soap.
TODD WOMACK: I know, right.
PAUL SCHEER: Come on.
TODD WOMACK: So Paul.
PAUL SCHEER: Yes.
TODD WOMACK: Everyone
is dying to know--
what is your middle name.
PAUL SCHEER: My middle
name is Christian,
because my mom had
a tough childbirth,
and I guess that she felt like
she saw God in that childbirth.
So she said, I named you
Christian after, like,
Christianity?
Terrible.
But yeah, so that's how
my name became Christian.
TODD WOMACK: I
did not know that.
That was just a stupid, silly
question to throw you off.
And you're like, God.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
No, but my mom is not a super
religious person as much
as she may want
people to believe.
But she's not
like-- it's weird--
TODD WOMACK: Outside
of childbirth.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, and
then naming me Christian
after Christianity.
TODD WOMACK: Great.
So let's tell these guys-- I
actually had you as a teacher
at the UCB in 2003, and I've
done your comedy show Crash
Test, the live one a few times--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, yeah.
TODD WOMACK: --and you've
just been around forever.
So maybe you could just-- you've
just been doing so much stuff.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
When Mel Brooks and I started--
TODD WOMACK: Yeah, I'm
looking at your IMDB--
PAUL SCHEER: Show of Shows
was an interesting experience.
No, you're right.
I was lucky
because-- I feel bad,
because I don't want to
neglect you guys over here.
I'm going to make awkward
big motions like this.
TODD WOMACK: Those seats
are way cheaper than these,
so that's fine.
PAUL SCHEER: No, I was lucky.
I started off at UCB
back in-- I guess--
early 2000, if not even 1999.
I was going to college
at NYU, and somebody
was like, oh my god, you have
to see this group the Upright
Citizens Brigade.
And at that point I
was actually touring
around the country doing this
show called "Chicago City
Limits," which was kind
of cheesy short form,
where like, every
time this bell rings,
we're going to change the
last line of dialogue.
You know.
And we'd put on funny hats
and say we're gynecologists.
It was a really
top notch program.
And I was like, this is improv.
This is life.
I can't-- nothing
gets better than this.
And someone was like, you have
to go see the Upright Citizens
Brigade.
And I went to this-- I
walked up five flights
to go to the top of
this hardware store
where the UCB were performing
at the solo arts group.
And they do a show every Sunday
night, and my mind was blown.
They took one suggestion, they
improvised for 45 minutes,
and I believe in
that early time I
was seeing people like
Adam McKay and Tina Fey
and Miriam Tolan
and John Glaser.
All these amazingly
funny people.
It was just like, well
I gotta figure out
how to study with these guys.
And they weren't even teaching
classes at that point.
You could just
hire them privately
to coach an improv
or comedy group.
So they started
teaching classes.
I took a class
there, and then got
into that system, which has
now become this giant behemoth.
If I was me now trying
to get into UCB,
I don't know if I would
have ever gotten in.
It's just too hard.
They have two theaters in
New York, two theaters in LA,
and a bigger admission
process than most colleges.
They're just this
giant comedy entity.
When I first started there,
I was doing shows five nights
a week.
Not good shows, but shows.
Yeah, we just had
to fill the space.
We had a theater that was
open seven nights a week,
and I was doing five
of those nights.
Shows like Robot TV, which
was a show for robots
by robots, where we worship
someone called Landau
and there was a guy
on the side of stage
just playing electric
guitar shooting a slide
show where most of our
audience walked out of.
That was a constant thing.
We did a show called "The Real
Road Rules"-- or "Real World,"
which was a parody
of the "Real World."
We just were doing
so many shows.
That was my comedy
college, essentially.
Just working there
and doing that.
And then I started
teaching there and then
that's how I met you.
TODD WOMACK: And that group
of-- and everything went from
there--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: But that group--
was it Respecto Montalban?
You're like--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: You guys
are still kind of--
PAUL SCHEER: We
kind of do, yeah.
TODD WOMACK: You ever
perform together?
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: So this is
a group-- this is you--
PAUL SCHEER: Me, Rob
Riggle, Rob Huebel,
Chad Carter who's a
writer/producer for "The Daily
Show," Owen Burke who's the head
of "Funny or Die" At that time
when we were in New York,
it was Jackie Clarke, who's
a writer for "Happy Endings"
and a bunch of other stuff
right now.
And Dannah Phirman,
and Daniel Schneider
who created "The Hotwives" show.
And so it was a really--
and Jack McBrayer
was in that group.
One of the cool
things-- and this
is a thing I learned
early on-- was
the UCB would see people
and go, all right, you
and you and you, you guys
are all in a Harold team.
And they would pick people
and they'd feel like, oh,
that energy worked really well.
TODD WOMACK: And that's sort
of your long form improv team.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
This would be like,
you would go up
and you'd improvise for 30
minutes, and varying degrees
of being good.
And I got on my team
with Rob Riggle,
and we were like oh, I
really like Rob Huebel.
And he was like, yeah, and
I really like Owen Burke.
And we kind of broke
out of the UCB mold
and formed our own team.
And at that point no
one had done that yet.
And so we caused a lot of drama.
Like it was, again,
like you know
all the stuff-- like when you're
first starting out-- like we
broke up our own Harold teams.
And they're like, how
could you do that.
You know, we made enemies
with these people.
But it was really good, because
when we formed this team,
we've continued performing
together until this day.
We have a show every
Wednesday night at UCB in LA
that we still do with the
majority of that team.
TODD WOMACK: Is
that the Facebook?
PAUL SCHEER: It's
called Facebook.
TODD WOMACK: It used
to be the Myspace.
PAUL SCHEER: Used to be Myspace.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah, you guys
have been doing it a while.
PAUL SCHEER: Soon it
will be Periscope.
But yeah, no, we are trying
to change with the times.
TODD WOMACK: You guys just
bring up somebody and bring up
their--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, our
weekly show-- basically we
take a person in the
audience, we interview them
based on their Facebook
page, and then they
tell us the most insane
things about their lives.
They forget they're on stage.
Like, we had a therapist
tell us that he was treating
one of his patients at
a psychiatric hospital,
and started writing
her furlough just
to have weekend dates with her.
Which is crazy.
And unethical.
I'm not supporting it, but it
gave us really good fodder.
We had a woman who
recently got out
of a relationship-- a marriage--
and she had so much sex
that she put herself
in the hospital
for having too much sex.
We had a woman who
delivered a baby on the 405.
Like, people have
all these stories,
and you never think of it
when you look at their page.
Like, what was happening here?
Oh, that's when I
just gave birth.
Oh really?
Like, when did you give birth?
Oh, it was a couple weeks ago.
Oh, was it a hard birth?
Well it's kind of crazy because
I did it on the highway.
Like, wait, what?
So it's always this five
step kind of question,
and then you find
these amazing nuggets.
And then we improvise scenes
based on their life story.
TODD WOMACK: And you guys
have such a great-- that crew
is just power packed.
Such a great-- tons
of funny people.
PAUL SCHEER: It's
a super fun group.
And now we all kind of basically
work and hire each other.
How many people here have
been too UCB New York?
A lot?
A handful?
All right, good.
Well it's a good
place for comedy.
And they don't-- and
they're kind of agnostic.
You can do an improv show,
you can do a sketch show,
you can do whatever you
wanted to do in that realm.
It's not like Second City
which does a sketch show,
or "Groundlings," which
has a main stage show.
TODD WOMACK: A sketch
show where you have hats
and you play gynecologists--
PAUL SCHEER: Exactly,
yeah, exactly.
TODD WOMACK: Scenes where
people are naming their child's
middle name after God.
PAUL SCHEER: So yeah.
So we've kind of been
taking that aesthetic
and trying to bring
it out a little bit.
So we all have created shows
and work with each other
all the time.
TODD WOMACK: So on of the
coolest things that you've
got coming up is "Crash Test."
PAUL SCHEER: Yes.
TODD WOMACK: It's the
show-- you guys have been
doing that on and off forever.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
We've been-- Rob
Huebel, Aziz Ansari
and I did the show on
MTV called "Human Giant."
It was a sketch show that
was on MTV at a time when we
had no business being on MTV.
MTV was like, hey,
we want you guys
to do a sketch show for us.
And we were like, why are
an older man, a bald dude,
and a little Indian guy.
Like what-- you
have "The Hills,"
and the prettiest
people basically
doing zit cream commercials.
Why would you want us?
And they really just
were like, no, we
want to have this energy of MTV.
So against all odds,
they put us on the air.
We looked like nothing else.
And like, we were always
invited to the parties
where we were like the
ugliest people there.
But we were not
the accepcted type.
I remember there's
a picture of me
and Aziz and Rob with like
Joe Francis and everybody
from "The Hills."
It's like what
doesn't belong here.
The three of us.
And I remember that because
Joe Francis put his arms
around us-- Joe
Francis of course
created the great "Girls
Gone Wild" franchise.
I think he may be in prison.
He says, everyone say scumbags!
And we're like, oh,
we're not scumbags.
TODD WOMACK: We have
a television show.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
So but we got to do this show.
And one of the
things that you do
when you're working
on shows a lot
is you don't get a chance
to get to perform out.
And I think for all
of us, we always
wanted to make sure we
were getting on stage
and performing.
So we created this show
that was essentially
11 o'clock on Monday nights.
We would always be
able to make that,
because our shoot day
would never go that long.
So we started doing
the show Crash Test,
and Rob and I have
continued doing it.
And the show can be
anything that you want.
It's basically a chance for
Rob and I to mess around.
We've had, like,
Yom Kippur on stage.
We didn't know what that was.
We had someone from the
audience teach us it.
We went to the supermarket,
bought supplies, and then
did it.
We've sent people
out on blind dates.
We've done dating games.
We did a whole
show via-- what was
that thing at one point where
it was just-- Chatroulette.
And we open up Chatroulette.
And we went through, and
Tig Notaro was performing,
and someone was like, my
god, Tig, and freaked out.
So we have like--
it's a place where
you can do whatever you wanted.
And we were always like, I want
to do this show as a special.
I want to do it as something.
But it's not really
a stand up show.
It's not really a sketch show.
It's kind of just
this other thing.
This thing that's kind
of very unique to UCB.
And so we didn't
know how to do it.
And then at one time
we were like, what
would be great if we actually
did the show on a moving bus.
And then Ben Stiller
found out about it,
and he's like, yeah, let's
go get you guys that bus.
TODD WOMACK: I was wondering
how you got that bus.
PAUL SCHEER: We
were like, really?
Then we're like,
all right, great!
And Ben Stiller-- we
said to Paramount,
we want to do the
special on a moving bus.
Ben's behind it.
And they're like, well,
what's the script?
And we're like,
there is no script.
And they were like,
well, we need a script.
And Ben's like, no they don't.
And they're like, no they don't.
And then we got this bus from
42nd Street in Times Square.
It's a glass bus, which
we'll see in a second.
We shipped it out to LA,
and then we just basically
improvised a special.
We shot for six hours and we
bump into all of our friends
like Aziz Ansari, Aubrey
Plaza, Rob Corddry.
Earl Sweatshirt improvises
a musical-- musical--
he basically does
a live music video.
And everything-- we
never met anybody
before we pulled up
to them at their stop.
And we were-- yeah.
Everything was over
text and email.
It was the most fun, because
that bus-- whatever we said,
we could yell at
people in the street.
Like there was a
guy tipping a valet,
and we had the whole bus
start chanting, tip him more,
tip him more, tip
him-- and no one
knows what this is, because
you've never seen a giant glass
bus rolling down the street.
Like, at one point we
all had ski masks on.
And were like, and we're trying
to be as creepy as we could.
TODD WOMACK: Like all 60 people?
PAUL SCHEER: Just yeah, like
60 people all in ski masks.
So it was a great
kind of experiment.
And we did one thing--
one of my favorite pieces
in the whole thing was we
gave a guys-- a random guy,
we never met this
guy-- an ear bud.
And we said, go out
onto Hollywood Boulevard
where the Walk of Fame
is, and just start--
say whatever we tell you.
And he said whatever
we told him.
And I think he just had no fear.
Because we were like, go up
to that woman, sniff her hair,
tell her she's pretty.
And he did it.
And he never had any hesitation.
It was like we
programmed this robot.
And so he got to like
just-- one of the most--
it was a great
moment that we didn't
think we were going to
even do in the actual show.
TODD WOMACK: How did you
keep the crowds energy up
for six hours? were they--
PAUL SCHEER: It was
fun because I think
it was that we were having fun.
We didn't know what
was going to happen.
And a lot of times when you go
to a live taping of whatever--
"Big Bang Theory,"
whatever-- you
see the same scene three times.
We never did anything twice.
The bus was moving.
You were on a tour.
And instead of watching
like a small TV
with like "Furious
Seven" on it, you
were just watching us
interact with celebrities.
And they didn't know
who was coming up next.
They don't know if they're
going to get on the bus.
No one knew what
was going to happen.
So I feel like it just had
the energy of all right,
yeah, sure, we're in.
What will be next.
TODD WOMACK: Did you know
that the "Reno 911" guys--
Thomas Lennon and Ben Garant--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah,
Ben Garant, Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: --did you know that
they were going to be the cops?
Or were you just like--
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, we knew
everybody's ultimate game.
Like, we knew Rob was
going to do a yard sale.
But we didn't know where
that was going to go per se.
We knew that Aubrey was going
to be burying a dead body.
We basically wrote
it enough-- like,
sketch probbed it in a way,
where we would be like,
hey, you're burying a dead body,
we bump into you, you blame us.
All right, and then Rob,
you're selling stuff,
you have a Boston accent, you're
not speaking your own accent.
So we were able to
kind of go in there
and know that we had something.
But every piece is
really cut down tight.
TODD WOMACK: So that's
going to come out on Vimeo.
PAUL SCHEER: It is
actually already out.
It's been out for a while now.
So-- but don't worry about it.
That's fine.
It uh--
TODD WOMACK: Sorry.
I work at YouTube, man,
I don't look at Vimeo.
I'd get fired if I do that.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
And for anybody internationally,
it's available internationally
on Vimeo.
And then now on iTunes.
It just came out and
iTunes a few weeks ago.
Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: Any plans
to do more of that?
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah we wanted
to do another "Crash Test."
And we actually
have a way, I think,
to trump it now and make it even
more drastic-- yeah, airplane.
Duck boat.
Yeah I know, yeah.
So that's been a
really-- it was fun
to be able to kind of
experiment with that.
I feel like the
one thing I like is
that you're able to mix in a
little bit more sloppy-- that's
not the best word,
but less polished.
And that's something I
feel like-- we're so used
to seeing everything
all like-- when you see
a stand up special,
it's all perfectly
rehearsed and everything.
But I think one of the charms
of going to a comedy club
or going to see people is that
anything can kind of happen,
and that's what we
wanted to do on the bus.
TODD WOMACK: Great.
Check that out-- one month ago.
What else?
So you have some other
digital stuff coming out.
Let me just prep the--
so we have you probably
till 2:50 up here.
PAUL SCHEER: Should we
just answer questions
from the audience?
Could that happen?
Or maybe we won't even have--
TODD WOMACK: Let's do
a couple more minutes,
and then we'll
ask for questions.
So if you guys have a
question, think about it,
and we'll have you come up to
either of these microphones.
PAUL SCHEER: You could
ask about your own life.
I'm going to give you advice.
We can get over issues
with your parents.
So we can really treat
this as like a good group
therapy session.
We'll problem solve together.
TODD WOMACK: This is an
intervention bye the way.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, this
is-- for one of you.
We don't know which one yet.
No, yeah.
I've been doing
a bunch of stuff.
I just recently
finished a new series
for Maker tentatively
titled "Filthy Sexy Teens."
But apparently that did
not pass legal standards.
TODD WOMACK: I thought
you were going to say,
that title is taken.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, no.
It is, I'm sure.
I think we were like,
it's a great title.
They were like, yeah, but if
you Google filthy sexy teens,
It's going to not
necessarily get to our show.
And the show is
really for 14-year-old
to like 20-year-old girls.
So you're really
going like, yeah mom,
I want to watch a show
called "Filthy Sexy Teens."
Google that and
like all of a sudden
a world is opened up that you
can never close the door to.
But yeah, no-- and I
recently just finished
doing the second
season of "Hotwives,"
which is a show I
produced for Hulu,
which is a parody of "The
Real Housewives" worlds.
But I've basically
been doing all these--
in addition to doing things
like "The League" and "Fresh
off the Boat" and
stuff like that.
All these things in
the digital space.
And one of the things about
"Crash Test" we really
want to do is to make it
ourselves and self release it.
Because there's sort
of-- we wanted to kind of
be platform agnostic.
Sometimes it's very
hard to get something.
Like, oh, if everyone
watches "House of Cards,"
then all of a sudden I got
to spend $7.99 for Netflix.
Not that that's a waste, but
if you don't want to do that,
then you've got to-- you've got
to-- just to watch one thing.
We want to make it on a platform
where anyone could get it--
all you need to do
is pay us the money.
Which seemed like the best plan.
TODD WOMACK: So you
got that thing--
I saw something-- some
cartoon called "White Ninja"?
PAUL SCHEER: Oh
Yeah. "White Ninja"
is a new thing that I'm doing.
Finally Vine is coming
out with a TV series.
They're are six second TV series
called "White Ninja," which
is-- I think when the
internet first started,
"White Ninja" was a thing.
It was kind of this crudely
drawn, black and white
comic book about
this white ninja who
is just really a real jerk.
And so Vine is like, yes,
that's our first show.
And so we did a six second show.
And it's a daily show.
But one of the recording
process for that
was insane, because you
have to cram everything
into six seconds.
No matter what the dialogue, no
matter who you're interacting
with, you'd be like,
that was great,
but that was eight seconds.
Sorry, gotta do it again.
So it was almost a race
to get every word out
in time before it relooped.
So hopefully that
will turn out good.
TODD WOMACK: I saw that it
was going to be on Vine,
I just assumed it was going
to not be six seconds long.
PAUL SCHEER: No.
100% six seconds.
Yeah.
It is--
TODD WOMACK: How did you fit
in all those six second audio
like into your schedule?
Who has that kind of time?
PAUL SCHEER: I know.
It was really-- we did
them all individually,
which was really dumb.
We should have just
block shot them all.
TODD WOMACK: In one 25 minute.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
We would go there for
about three minutes.
Leave.
Come back.
TODD WOMACK: 100 episodes done.
PAUL SCHEER: It really is.
I imagine like-- we did
about 40 or 50 episodes.
I think it probably is a sum
total of like 40 minutes.
Maybe.
At most.
It can't.
It can't even be 40 minutes.
Math whizzes, what is it?
TODD WOMACK: It's 20.
PAUL SCHEER: Well the
question-- the line is
just daunting at the Q&A posts.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
Oh hey.
There's Alan, stoking
the fire over there.
ALAN: Yeah.
I'm going to start it off.
So we're now in the final
season of "The League."
Sad face.
I was wondering if
you could talk about--
PAUL SCHEER: Say sad face emoji.
Because we can just
see your sad face.
But if you say sad face
emoji, then we know.
ALAN: Hashtag sad face.
TODD WOMACK: You
live emoji-d it.
ALAN: I was wondering
if you could
talk about how that has sort
of shaped your career, being
on "The League."
And then if you had a favorite
story you like to tell,
we'd love to hear it.
PAUL SCHEER: Oh yeah.
Well "The League" is a
really interesting story,
because it was a show
that I almost didn't do.
I think every thing
that I've ever gotten,
I've been adamantly like,
I'm never doing that.
It's no, not interested.
And it was about--
because it was
a show about fantasy football.
I was like, I can't improvise
about fantasy football.
Who does fantasy football?
No one.
TODD WOMACK: That
was 2009, right?
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: Since then
it's become a huge business.
PAUL SCHEER: It was
definitely prevalent,
and there were people who
knew about it, and it was big.
But I was doing fantasy
football before there
were apps on your phone.
It was a little bit different.
And it's grown.
Now DraftKings--
and the government's
investigating DraftKings--
we've come so far.
But the audition for the
show was really interesting,
because it was the perfect
opportunity for a show for me,
because basically
it's improvised.
You get to do whatever you want.
You're going to
create your character
and you're going to
improvise with these people.
It was being created by Jeff
Schaffer and Jackie Schaffer.
Jeff wrote on "Seinfeld" and
writes and directs "Curb"
and was on all the Sacha
Baron Cohen movies.
So it was an
amazing opportunity.
And that show has
been-- I've been
very lucky to be involved
with very cool shows.
Like the first show
that I ever did--
and even if it feels
lame now, I did
this a show called
"Best Week Ever," which
was just like-- thank you.
Thank you.
Aw.
Yeah, we used to talk
about Ben and Jen.
The old Jen.
J-Lo.
But no, it was like-- I've
been on these shows that
have a really crazy fan base.
And "Best Week Ever" was one,
and "Human Giant" was another.
But "The League" opened up this
world where it was like, wow.
People have loved this show and
it's been really fun to make.
And we get to work with a real
diverse group, Mark Duplass
and Katie who come from
the independent film world.
Nick Kroll who-- we actually
were friends, so no big
deal on him.
Jon Lajoie is a guy
who was a Canadian soap
star who then became a YouTube
star making these funny rap
songs.
And Steve Rannazzisi
who is a stand up comic.
And all these different
people from all
these different backgrounds
who came in and we just
really jelled as a group.
So that's been great.
Even to this day we're just
still having fun on set.
And I guess as far is
favorite stories-- it's always
interesting because--
the show can dictate
whatever you want it to be.
For example, I
referenced in one episode
that I have a blog dedicated
to Don Henley music and magic.
And one of the best things
about that was an episode later,
we were able to make
that blog in the show.
So it's kind of like the show
in itself is a magic trip.
You're like, whatever you say
can come true in an episode.
TODD WOMACK: Some intern
has to spend all night.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah it's
like, here it goes,
we'll write a scene
where we see your blog.
Yeah.
It's funny.
In seven years, the whole
show kind of blurs together.
So whenever people ask me, oh,
what's your favorite moment,
I'm like, well, what we shot
last week was really fun.
Because it's only the
last thing I remember.
But the one moment
that I feel like kind
of jelled the whole
show is in the pilot,
we were doing the scene
around this joint.
My first joint
that I ever smoked.
But it turned out it was pubes.
Hilarious.
And I'm trying to
cheers everybody.
I'm saying, so a toast
to my good friends.
And everyone started drinking
before the toast started.
And I was like, oh, OK, hold on,
I'm just-- I'm making a toast.
To my-- drink, drink.
Oh, hey.
And this whole bit got
started about them drinking
before I finished my toast.
And it was all improvised.
And I was like, oh my gosh.
This is the ability
of this show.
I'm never going to have
that opportunity again.
And it's been like that since
day one all the way to now--
is just on the spot, going,
oh, how about if we do this.
How about it we do this.
And everything comes together.
And I think for me, one of
the most daunting moments
of the show was in
the second season.
We had Terrell
Suggs on the show.
He's a very
intimidatingly big man.
And the one I've learned--
and I've learned this thing--
every time I meet
a football player,
I assume they're older than me.
I think I'm still always
a kid, and they're
like 20 younger than me.
They're like, hi, I'm 15.
I'm like, oh, OK.
But they're-- we all come out
of the machine like at 100%.
They come out of the
machine at like 150%.
Like J. J. Watt is a giant man.
Like you stand next to him--
he's like an astro mech
from "Pacific Rim."
I could step inside him.
Controlling you.
They're big.
And you never know how they're
going to take anything.
TODD WOMACK: Seven years
on a show about football,
and you've learned that
football players are big.
PAUL SCHEER: It never
ceases to amaze me.
Because you see them,
but in real life
when they're standing next to
you, you feel just smaller.
I can't express
it more than that.
I would say two
moments stick out.
Well-- OK, I can
tell this story.
I'll tell them both.
One I just have to
not name any names.
So Terrell Suggs on the show.
And my character Andre is
having an all white party.
Right.
And it was just you
had to wear white.
And then I had to go up to
Terrell Suggs and say, sorry.
He was not wearing white.
And I had to kind of kick him--
it was a really crazy scene.
They're like, we don't
want to tell Terrell
what you're going to say.
Just go up to him
and say, all white.
And we want to get his honest
reaction the first take.
I never have been more
nervous in my life.
Because he never even
met me, the show was new,
and I think he was like,
why am I on this show.
And I think, like,
am I being pranked.
But to his credit,
he was so funny.
I said it to him, and he clicked
in, and then was improvising.
And I still say, Terrell Suggs
is the best football improviser
that we've had on the show.
He was amazing.
Second story that
was kind of crazy
was we had a monkey on the show.
A capuchin monkey that
was clearly not trained.
The one thing that you learn
when you work in TV and movies
is there are all
these animal trainers,
but they don't train anything.
They don't know these are
animals and they're wild.
Someone's like, oh,
I'm the snake trainer.
Like, you don't train a snake.
How do you train a snake?
They're a snake.
TODD WOMACK: No.
No.
PAUL SCHEER: They are like--
they literally have a stick
and they're like poking it.
TODD WOMACK: I've trained the
snake to react when I poke it.
TODD WOMACK: You're
hitting a snake.
So the larger the animal,
the more risks you're taking.
So we had this monkey.
And the whole idea
was he's a ghost
monkey, does it really exist, or
maybe it wasn't, I don't know.
He did exist in
real life for me.
And I'm driving my car and
he gets loose in the car.
And so the only way
to do that is to have
a monkey loose in a moving car.
And the monkey went crazy and
started attacking the visor.
Like eating the
visor of the car.
I'm on the road like on a
platform car, freaking out,
and the trainer is
hiding in the back seat.
So if anything goes
wrong, he can't get there.
And the trainer, he's like--
I'm going, he's freaking out,
he's freaking out,
what should we do.
He's like, give him
the Sour Patch Kids,
give him the Sour Patch Kids.
Which didn't seem like
a great idea to me.
TODD WOMACK: Here's some sugar.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, like--
this is not in book.
It's sugar in the
shape of a human.
Giving him the wrong idea.
So yeah.
I did not like working
with that monkey.
TODD WOMACK: Question.
AUDIENCE MEMBER:
Everything I've ever
read about--
anything about comedy
says that comedy is
the hardest thing
to do of out of even
drama or anything else.
Why is that?
What is it that makes comedy--
and people that do other stuff
try and do comedy and
say it was the hardest
thing I've ever done.
PAUL SCHEER: Well
maybe because it's
like-- if I came and
tried to do your job,
it would be the hardest
thing I ever did.
I feel like I think
it's hard because if you
try to make a
transition-- I feel
like I wouldn't go up here and
be like, yeah, improv is tough.
Like really had a
tough improv show.
But that's what I've been doing
for-- I couldn't make a show.
But I'm sure if you said to a
cobbler, is making shoes hard,
he'd be like, no, I
do this all the time.
As you saw in the great Adam
Sandler movie "The Cobbler."
You know, I don't know.
I think the one thing that I
do know that maybe people don't
want to do is look foolish.
I certainly look foolish
all the time, especially
on "The League."
My characters dress
as much as a clown
as you can possibly get
without being a clown.
But I think it's
maybe looking foolish.
And you have to
give supreme trust
in a lot of different people.
I think for something
to work comedically--
and it's not on stage--
if it's on film,
the editors have to be with you.
The director has to be with.
Your scene partners
have to be with you.
So it's a lot of trust.
Whereas if you have someone
amazing Benedict Cumberbatch
or something-- if he gives a
fucking awesome-- can we curse?
I'm sorry.
That clip had a
million curses in it.
And I'm like
holding back curses.
TODD WOMACK: It's OK.
PAUL SCHEER: You can give
an amazing performance
and walk away, and
it would be like,
oh that performance was amazing.
I think comedy requires a little
bit more of a group effort
and a trust in the group.
And I think that
that's a daunting thing
to give that over.
And Jim Carrey I guess
does it by himself.
But I don't--
But I think maybe
that there's a fear,
and you have to be open to it.
But yeah. and I guess
ultimately, too,
if you fail at
comedy, it's apparent.
If you fail at drama,
it's like-- eh.
No one will be like--
TODD WOMACK: It's a choice.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah,
no one will be like--
and you have to really fail at
drama badly for someone to be
like, they're a bad actor.
Like "The Room,"
that's some bad acting.
But there's a lot of middle
of the road bad drama.
Like I mean, turn on any
"NCIS," you're going to be like,
yeah, that's fine.
But like comedy, it's like
it's good or it's not.
it's like that's it.
There's like, I
laughed, or I didn't.
Like drama, you're not
like, he didn't move me.
So maybe that's it.
There's a very black and white.
TODD WOMACK: What is your
job, if we could ask?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I work
on one of the ad products.
It's called Double Click.
TODD WOMACK: What is your title?
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I'm
an escalation manager.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah, see,
I couldn't do that.
TODD WOMACK: I think
you could do that.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: I could teach
you to do it very quickly.
PAUL SCHEER: I can't even
organize my Google Docs.
Come on.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Neither can we.
TODD WOMACK: We got
another one over here.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: So
I'll start with why
I'm asking the
question, which is
before this season
of "The League,"
I feel like my overwhelming
emotion for Andre was pity.
And after this seaons
of "The League"--
and I don't want to ruin
it for people, why--
but now it's more like
despise-- like I hate him.
And I guess Jack Gleeson, who
played King Joffrey in "Game
of Thrones"-- he told you
about how his character has had
consequences in his real life.
Does that happen to you?
PAUL SCHEER: Oh interesting.
Well, we are like the "Game of
Thrones" of fantasy football.
You know, one of
the things I tried
to do early on in the show-- if
I've done anything calculated
in my career, it was to distance
myself a little bit from Andre,
because the last thing I wanted
to do was be viewed as Andre.
I think that like,
Matt LeBlanc-- I mean,
he's apparently amazing on
"Episodes"-- but you think, oh,
that's Joey from "Friends."
I didn't want to be just that.
So one of the things I
tried to do right away
was do this Adult
Swim show like "NTSF,"
and be like doing a Jack
Bauer "24" type of character.
So very different.
And I tried to embrace
things like that.
I feel like Twitter
and stuff like
that-- people will come up and
be like, yo, Dre, what up-- I
think people call you
by your name a lot.
That's the consequences.
I think King-- is it
Joffrey or Jeffrey?
They probably won't call him
King Joffrey out and about,
but I feel like whenever
I'm in any airport
or public situation, it's
like, Andre, what's up.
TODD WOMACK: You
also have those fans
who are like football fans.
PAUL SCHEER: Yes.
And so I think the
biggest consequence
of being on this show is people
ask me about fantasy football
all the time.
And I am not a wealth of
fantasy football knowledge.
I know about my teams and
I don't care about yours.
And nor would I expect
you to care about mine.
But I feel like people are
always like, let me ask you--
who should I start
in [INAUDIBLE]?
And it's a crazy question,
because it's so specific
based on who's in
your league, where
are you, who are you playing.
It's like-- so yeah, so I
think the biggest consequence
is that.
And also I could
probably never wear
a hat that's not a baseball cap.
Like there was a moment like
I was away on a vacation,
and there was-- I
would say a respectful
looking-- it wasn't a fedora,
but it was kind of a beach hat.
I don't know how
you describe it.
And I was like, no, there's
no way I could ever wear that.
Because then I'm like,
oh he is like that guy.
He wears that.
I do not want to be that.
So I am extra cautious about
how I dress, and I can never
wear a hat.
So whenever I am
out and about, it's
a baseball cap 100% of the time.
And as a bald man,
I need hat options.
And I have no hat options.
TODD WOMACK: I
got a lot of hats.
Some cool hats.
PAUL SCHEER: Yeah.
I only can wear a
ball cap though.
I feel like any other hat will
put me in that Andre category.
TODD WOMACK: Hey, I
was watching football
with Nick Kroll in a
bar a couple of years
ago with a couple
other comedian friends.
And-- it was one
of those ones where
you have a bunch of
football games on in a bar--
and he just got attacked
by everyone about football.
And I was like, oh my
god, what a weird fate.
TODD WOMACK: It's a crazy--
yeah, it's kind of crazy.
Yeah.
But I mean, the fans of "The
League" have been amazing.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah
they're big time into it.
PAUL SCHEER: Big time fans.
TODD WOMACK: Let's do
another one over here.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hi.
First off, thanks for coming.
Second of all, I'm a big
fan of your podcast "How
Did This Get Made" with Jason
Mantzoukas and June Diane
Raphael.
So my question
concerns the podcast,
which is, did you
ever figure out
what happened to the
man who threw away
the dog in "Mr. Nanny"?
PAUL SCHEER: Well, it's really
interesting you bring that up,
because-- I thank you for that.
So I do this bad movie podcast
called "How Did This Get Made."
We basically watch a movie
and then just talk about it.
So it's like a conversation.
And it's been really fun.
And one of the
movies that we did
was a movie called "Mr.
Nanny" with Hulk Hogan.
You could figure it out.
The plot-- it's all there,
right there in the title.
But there's an opening
sequence in the film
where Hulk Hogan is driving
his motorcycle down--
it's a beauty shot of Florida.
And in the background-- and
it's not called attention to,
and only when you slow
it down do you see it--
there's a guy with a dog in
his hand, and he's like this.
Tosses a dog into a river.
Or a body of water.
I don't wanna be-- I don't know
what the body of water-- and he
tosses is out.
And we pointed that out.
And it had been
pointed out before us,
we were not the
ones to find this.
But someone pointed it out,
and we showed it again.
And it became a big
topic of conversation.
Recently someone
emailed me and said,
I figured out why that
guy was throwing the dog.
And apparently that is a lake
in which dogs can swim in it.
So if they were
shooting it, that
may have just been
an a-hole owner
who was like, get in there.
So he was doing the
right thing-- ish.
Dogs do belong in that lake.
But I don't know if I agree
with the way he was putting him
in that lake.
Yeah.
But we've actually done
something really cool
with the show.
We partnered up with
this guy Blake Harris.
Blake Harris wrote this
book called "Console Wars"
about Sega and Nintendo.
And he's actually been
doing-- because the biggest
complaint of our show is,
how did this get made?
We're not going to tell you.
We don't know.
We're just going to talk
about what we thought
was ridiculous about it.
He is actually doing the
how did this get made
of "How Did This Get
Made" He's been going back
and interviewing people.
We just did "Masters of the
Universe" with Tatyana Maslany
from "Orphan Black."
And he went back and he
talked to people from Mattel,
and he talked to
people on the movie,
and he gets the full
behind the scenes story.
So hopefully, if we ever come
across a "Mr. Nanny" situation,
we're going to able to break
that story much quicker
in the future.
Yeah.
TODD WOMACK: I think we've got
time for one more question.
Let's go over there.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Hey Paul.
I'm actually also a Huge fan
of "How Did This Get Made."
PAUL SCHEER: Oh,
thank you so much.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: Just
given how many projects
you're in, and how time
consuming they must all be--
especially "NTSF," "Crash
Test," and "The League"--
do you plan on continuing to
do podcasts as long as you can
based on how a lot easier
they must be to manage?
PAUL SCHEER: You know, to
me a podcast-- and Jason
and I were talking
about the other day.
Jason Matsoukas and I,
we started off at UCB.
And it's been a
really fun thing.
But the best part of UCB-- and
I talked about this earlier--
is it's great to have a
place to get up and perform.
You have to just be in
front of an audience,
because that's where
we all started.
And I still perform twice
a week at UCB most weeks.
And podcasts have
that same feeling.
You can just kind of show up.
Me, for the podcast, I
have to do a lot more work,
because I'm kind of
the-- I just have
to do a lot more work
than Jason and June.
They just watch the movie and
show up. [INAUDIBLE] sometimes.
But I do have good interns that
help me put together stuff.
But it is fun, and it's easy.
And the benefit of doing all
the things that I am doing
is that they're all
in short intervals.
So The League is 12
weeks out of the year.
And so that doesn't
take up that much time.
And when we shot "Hotwives,"
which was eight half hours,
or seven half hours--
it was only 10 days.
So we're shooting in these
compact periods of time.
So yeah.
As much as we can
do it, we can do it.
We've been erring more on
the side of live shows,
because they're easier to book.
And we're like, well, we got
to show up and make a podcast
there.
So that's why we do a
lot more live shows.
Because I think if it's
booked, we'll definitely do it.
I feel like we've got to
take this guy's question.
TODD WOMACK: Yeah.
That was a quick one.
AUDIENCE MEMBER: It's
kind of a quick one.
So I know "The
League" is improvised,
but I'm sure you guys have
to write some plot points
and stuff beforehand.
So I was wondering
how much is written,
and what extent it's improvised.
PAUL SCHEER: Well
yeah, I've actually
written a bunch of episodes over
the course of the seven years.
And so it's one of the
harder scripts to write,
because you have to write
a 12 page outline that
is a full story with full plot
lines and joke ideas in them,
but it has to be loose
enough that it doesn't feel
like you're writing a scene.
So it's this weird
middle ground of-- it's
almost like a very
detailed outline.
But some of the stuff in
the show that people really
like, like the terminology--
like fear boner, or Eskimo
brother, or stuff
like that-- that had
come from our show creators.
Jeff Schaffer worked
on "Seinfeld."
He was one of the
guys who created
the term regifted,
which I didn't know
was a "Seinfeld" term.
That is such in our lexicon,
but that came out of there.
And then I saw Eskimo
brothers on "The Bachelor"--
which, Bachelor.
I love "The Bachelor."
So good.
Oh my god, we've made
it, we've made it.
They're not saying,
like, on that show
"The League," Eskimo brothers.
They're like, no, no,
we're Eskimo brothers.
It's like, whoa, how
did that come in.
So yeah, there are
these touchstones
throughout the whole script.
And if you're not
an improvisors--
and we have a lot
of actors that come
on the show who are
not improvisors--
there's enough there.
Especially with our
football players.
We're like, hey, this is
what we're going to do,
we're really walking through it.
But what's so great about our
show is, when we start with
that the first take
we do as scripted.
But then we find a moment.
And in the second episode of
the season, we're doing a draft.
And in the draft I'm
kind of auctioning off
something going on there.
And Jason thinks that I'm
playing a game of password.
And he's like, things
a Cobb salad would say.
And I'd like, no.
What are you talking about?
And he's like, things
a Cobb salad would say.
I'm like, no, no.
And then we started playing
this big game of things
a Cobb salad say password.
And that became like
a chunk of the scene.
And that would never
happen anywhere else,
and that's not written anywhere.
So that's kind of the
benefit of the show,
is that we have enough
to make the show work.
But never have we left
that on the table.
Every scene primarily
starts at a place
and then grows into
a bigger place,
but we have to know at
the end of the scene
that Andre can't
go like, and then
I'm going to go to
the moon tomorrow.
We do have you know he's
got to go here, to go here,
to go here.
We've got to hit
the plot points.
TODD WOMACK: Awesome.
Well, thanks for
joining us Paul.
PAUL SCHEER: Thank you
so much for having me.
TODD WOMACK: Thank
you guys for coming.
Paul Scheer everybody.